bari vuole un pezzo di pizza no no no
sai che sono a dieta sicura sì però se
volevo fare va di moda adesso annusi la
pizza e maggio un finocchio un museo
come magneti hoc
annuso il blocco mari ma un pezzo era
tutta la mia pizza ma guarda che bello
il mio perché no adesso faccio una foto
troppo bello dall'alto dalla nato ciao
ragazzi come potete vedere oggi solo
healthy food infatti c'è stato mi dà
fastidio
l'ho già detto tu devi fare tu ignorano
tu non capisci niente come 60 capito lui
non hai via per sono insieme da poco
tempo
[Musica]
eto'o ma non è ancora finito quello che
dobbiamo andare mari un attimo io i miei
tempi si se gentilmente allora mi può
far sapere poi per quell altra questione
grazie mille si si arriva subito alla
riunione fissata per mercoledì alle
cinque e mezza adesso ti mando il link
grazie a un ciao ho visto sto video su
youtube
praticamente durava 30 minuti e trenta
minuti di gatti temi angolano ma ci
credi che li ho visti tutti mongioj
robbie youtube facciamo cagnolino vado
cenno però la tua moratti vuole tanto
bene chiedere un biscottino vini steduto
buono costo poche mani manca qualcosa
sì ora ci siamo
quanto mi piace ancora ancora arriva un
areoplanino da lontano dritto guarda
arriva dagli stati uniti d'america
poi passa dalla cina poi nuova zelanda e
arriva direttamente della bocconi
mare paritarie